wir schauen nach london seine freundin
lillian war die erste besucherin vorne
boris becker im gefängnis seit
mittlerweile einer woche sitzt die
tennislegende dort in haft kleine rand
beobachtungen die sonst so schick
gekleidete william trägt auf einmal puma
von oben bis unten dazu später mehr aber
was ist eigentlich hinter den
gefängnismauern passiert bild kennt alle
details zum ersten gefängnisbesuch
genauer gesagt bild live show von
gianina kirsch
thomas ich kann dir soviel verraten ein
romantisches dinner date in ones wörz
war das nicht syrien war die erste
besucherin von boris was es gerade ja
schon gesagt und es war spartanisch
spartanisch spartanisch spartanisch sie
saßen in einem besucherraum mit 36
anderen gefangenen und deren angehörigen
man kann sich also vorstellen wie voll
das denn da drin gewesen ist also keine
glasscheibe dazwischen und telefon es
gab tatsächlich keine glasscheibe
zwischen ihn sie saßen in einem raum sie
saßen an einem tisch keine glasscheibe
trennte die beiden dadurch konnten sie
auch händchen halten sie haben auch
händchen gehalten also sie hatten
körperkontakt am anfang als sie
reingekommen ist sollen die beiden sich
auch umarmt haben aber wie gesagt 36
andere mitinsassen und deren angehörige
insgesamt neun wächter waren da und
haben aufgepasst da dort das dort auch
alles so abläuft wie es ablaufen muss
boris becker hatte seine
häftlingskleidung an trug darüber eine
gelbe weste um ihn dann auch zu
identifizieren also damit man auch sieht
das eher ein häftling ist und nicht im
jahr
in der menge sozusagen untergeht und
lillian hat ihnen dann auch noch
versorgt sie hat ihm schokolade gekauft
sie hat ihm kaffee gekauft sie hat eben
auch eine cola gekauft die sachen die
sie ihm aber mitgebracht hat wir haben
sie ja gesehen wie sie mit einer puma
tasche ins gefängnis reingegangen ist
die soll er nicht da behalten haben aber
sie ist dorthin sie hat dort im
gefängnis was für ihn gekauft ja also
eine stunde lang hatten die beiden ja
wenn man so möchte ein bisschen
körperkontakt buch ist sehr verzweifelt
gewirkt haben und das ist das was wir
über das allererste treffen exklusiv
erfahren haben tja so weit ist es
gekommen man freut sich dann über ein
schokoriegel wir kamen nochmal auf
regeln zu sprechen janina ganz in puma
also und langsam fällt das irgendwie
auch becker selbst trägt unter seiner
anstaltskleidung angeblich auch mal
klamotten auch puma turnschuhe hat er
mit ins gefängnis genommen kann es sein
dass der deutsche
sportartikel-hersteller hier eine chance
für eine werbekampagne sieht auch die
hip hop mode kam schließlich aus dem
knast jetzt also puma der neuer prison
schick
so kennen wir unseren boris von früher
stolzes dynamisches werbegesicht immer
wieder auf der werre puma das ehemalige
tennis ass war in der vergangenheit
immer wieder das werbegesicht des
deutschen sportartikelherstellers
doch jetzt knast jetzt ist nichts mehr
wie früher
puma darf bum bum boris wohl weiter im
gefängnis tragen doch wo bleibt der
werbeeffekt für die marke wenn niemand
mehr boris zu gesicht bekommt ich glaube
dass das jede marke für sich bewerten
wird und bewerten muss auch puma
verhältnis zu boris becker jetzt
bewerten wird aber grundsätzlich kann
man natürlich auch sagen
guten wie in schlechten zeiten also
vielleicht auch jetzt zum athleten
stehen und sich eben nicht von ihm
abzuwenden vielleicht ist jetzt ja
becker freundin lillian die lösung am
donnerstag besuchte sie den sechs
maligen grand slam champion im gefängnis
und was fällt aufrecht
puma puma und nochmal pommer da stellt
sich jetzt doch die frage ist die
aufgabe des marken botschafters einfach
auf lillian übertragen worden puma
selbst äußerte sich gegenüber bild wie
folgt boris becker ist und bleibt teil
der puma familie zu weiteren
vertragsdetails äußern wir uns nicht
puma hat keinen vertrag mit lillian
monteiro sie ist aber eine sehr gute
freundin von puma vielleicht liegt ja in
der werblichen boris becker abstinenz
auch eine chance so phoenix aus der
asche mäßig warum nicht natürlich könnte
man überlegen auch danach das meine ich
eben damit in guten wie in schlechten
zeiten denn boris diese schwere
schwierigste phase seines lebens
hoffentlich gesund und gut übersteht
dann auch gemeinsam an neuen produkten
oder neuen themen zu arbeiten geben und
dass man es raus aus dem knast in die
mode branche schaffen kann hat schon die
süße kerl ihr bewiesen der amerikaner
jeremy mix war früher straßen
gangmitglied wurde verknackt und
startete nach seiner haftstrafe in der
mode ganz groß durch gut dass mit dem
modeln stellen wir bei boris jetzt mal
ein bisschen in frage aber wie wäre es
denn mit einer puma knast kollektion
steht unserem herrn becker auf jeden
fall gar nicht so schlecht
[Musik]
und janina es gibt noch ein heißes
gerücht heute ja die mit in britischen
medien spekulieren sehr sehr wild was
mit boris passiert wenn er dann aus dem
gefängnis raus ist denn er kann
angeblich abgeschoben werden boris
becker lebt ja seit fast zehn jahren in
england hat dort mittlerweile auch sein
hauptwohnsitz es aber kein britischer
staatsbürger und in england soll es so
sein dass wenn man länger als ein jahr
im knast im knast war in england dann
können diese menschen die keine
britischen staatsbürger sind wohl
abgeschoben werden was natürlich
dramatisch für boris wäre weil hamilton
ist ja immer sein zweites wohnzimmer
gewesen das hat er immer gesagt er hat
sogar in einer doku mal gesagt er würde
da gerne begraben werden dass wir gar
nicht mehr holen wir uns juristischen
beistand unbedingt aufzuklären wir haben
alexander stevens strafverteidiger jetzt
bei uns in der leitung ja es ist das
möglich was da spekuliert wird in der
britischen presse abschiebung nach dann
ja 13 monaten die er im gefängnis
ausharren muss um es mal so zu
formulieren
es ist nicht es ist nicht nur möglich
sondern auch üblich im übrigen auch in
deutschland in deutschland gelten
allerdings andere voraussetzungen aber
auch da ist es so wenn sie eine straftat
begehen eine schwere geschafft hat und
das für die allgemeine sicherheit
lichkeit und ordnung problematisch ist
dann kann man auch hier in deutschland
niemanden abschieben bzw ausweisen die
abschiebung ist dann letztlich nur die
konsequenz falls man nicht freiwillig
das land verlässt und in england ist es
seitdem die ok nicht mehr eu-mitglied
ist auch so dass man das noch mal
wirklich krass verschärft hat wie janina
schon richtig gesagt hat nach 12 wenn
man märz mehr als zwölf monaten
freiheitsstrafe verurteilt wird dann
können die engländer einen abschieben
also ausweisen es ging uns wer
entscheidet denn darüber am ende des
tages also ist das irgendwie ja muss da
jemand einspruch erheben muss da jemand
eine klage einreichen also auf wen kommt
es jetzt an weil für buches wäre das
höchst dramatisch
also letzten endes ist es schon eine
automatismus das entscheiden die
behörden es gibt sogar noch die
möglichkeit dass der minister selbst der
zuständige minister also in dem fall der
innenminister selbst darüber entscheidet
ob jemand ausgewiesen wird oder nicht
auch diese möglichkeit besteht in
england von dem her
scheinen die sterne was das angeht nicht
allzu gut zu stehen denn boris becker
ist er zu einer mehrjährigen haftstrafe
verurteilt worden natürlich vorhin
gesagt des lebens wenn er eine gefahr
für die sicherheit und ordnung ist so
wäre es in deutschland jetzt gehen wir
nicht davon aus dass boris becker eine
gefahr für sicherheit und ordnung in
london wäre wo er erlebt gibt es da noch
irgendwie eine möglichkeit dass da
sozusagen gnade vor recht ergehen kann
es ist eine ermessensentscheidung
ähnlich wie in deutschland auch nur mit
strengeren vorschriften seitdem england
oder die ganze uk aus der eu ausgetreten
ist von dem er gibt es natürlich immer
möglichkeiten das anders zu sehen
es muss ja auch irgendwo verhältnismäßig
sein andererseits stellt sich natürlich
die frage warum sollte man boris becker
da anders behandeln als zahlreiche
andere kriminelle auch
das steht dann auf einem anderen blatt
er muss wohl auf die liebe der engländer
vertrauen
[Gelächter]